elle répondait pas la fin du monde
espoirs donc notre notre travail c'est
de pouvoir essayer de renforcer de texte
qui est nous a été proposé
[Musique]
déposer des marqueurs notamment sur la
labellisation des maisons sport santé
qui doit être reconnu par la loi avec
les actions et les missions qui sont
confiées à ces maisons support santé en
terme d'accueil et d'orientation de
formation des professionnels mais de
leur côté le vrai sujet sur lequel on
doit débattre sur le sport santé c'est
la prise en charge par l'assurance de la
sécurité sociale aujourd'hui le
gouvernement n'a pas franchi le pas et
donc on regrette on pouvait pas le faire
du côté du sénat parce qu'on peut pas
déposer des amendements qui engagent des
finances de l'état donc on nous aurait
proposé l'article 40
même déposé des amendements sur le sport
à l'école avec un amendement qui
impose une activité physique et sportive
à l'école quotidien c'est la présence du
sport qu'il soit quotidien c'est aussi
un travail avec le monde de l'entreprise
pour permettre aussi aux salariés de
pouvoir utiliser les maux de dos pour se
déplacer au travail mais aussi de
pouvoir avoir des activités physiques
dans les temps de repos entre midi et
deux heures c'est bien sûr le soutien et
l'accompagnement des sportifs de haut
niveau voilà c'est tout des dispositifs
que nous avons inclus dans ce texte qui
permette le développement de la pratique
[Musique]
je pense qu'il ya urgence à vraiment à
prendre une une règle qui soit pouvoir
être appliqué et qui permettra surtout
aux fédérations aux clubs et aux
responsables qui peuvent se retrouver en
avance le problème avec des des
participants qui porterait des 6 200 à
thouars sur sur un terrain de sport de
respecter la règle olympiques c'est la
neutralité sur les terrains de sport
voilà ce qu'on demande depuis des années
que le gouvernement n'a pas le courage
de prendre comme disposition alors j'ai
rencontré des présidents de fédérations
et des présidents de clubs qui
malheureusement se retrouve devant ce
phénomène et qui ont là la difficulté à
gérer parce que ça crée des tensions et
puis ce n'est pas un bon signal envoyé
sur la cohésion sociale il faut qu'on
évite aussi que des clubs communautaires
ce secret là mais n'y soit le
gouvernement nous explique cessé d
épiphénomène mais c'est des
épiphénomènes qui vont prendre toujours
plus d'importance je pense qu'il faut
mieux anticipé cette situation et être
très clair pour permettre fédération ou
club et à tous ceux qui se retrouvent
devant ce problème d'avoir une loi sur
lesquels il peut s'appuyer
[Musique]